it wasn't easy to track these down and i  got a shoe for you to rock you're a big  guy so i had to think about comfort so  these shoes are for you  they're the sake sakai and nike collab  you know the vaporizers because you  vaporize people and these these are hard  to find for a big guy you have a  japanese company that collabs and now i  haven't put red laces in them  so it actually represents the flag of  your your home country so they're comfy  you got rock sandals on now let's go  ahead and burn those and we can put  those on doug  so this is just for you man thank you  very much and when your knees better  those will be good to run in good with  jeans you're gonna fly flying back to  africa in those man they're dope  [Music]  super thick boy